ya hicimos varios videos en los cuales
aproximábamos el área por debajo de la
gráfica de una función utilizando
rectángulos este dibujo viene del primer
ejemplo que vimos en el cual todos los
rectángulos tenían el mismo largo que
era delta xy vimos que era de menos a
entre n y la altura estaba dada por la
función evaluada en el extremo izquierdo
a partir de ahí obteníamos en notación
sigma esta expresión de acá que justo el
fx y menos 1 indicaba la altura y el
delta x indicaba el largo por lo tanto
esto esto era una suma de áreas que
aproximaba el área por debajo de la
curva después platicamos que podíamos
cambiar la altura podíamos evaluar la
función en el extremo derecho o en el
punto medio y también jugamos un poco
con trapecios pero resulta que todas
estas cosas que hicimos son un caso
particular de algo que se conoce como
sumas de rima
voy a poner aquí sumas de rima
y las sumas de rimas son una noción más
general en la cual pues incluso podemos
cambiar a otras figuras geométricas o
también podemos pensar en que las
longitudes de cada una de esas figuras
ya es distinta al principio nosotros la
hicimos con la misma longitud para que
todo quedara pues conceptualmente más
sencillo pero bueno mira acá tenemos una
imagen de bernat rima él fue un
matemático muy famoso y colaboró con
muchas contribuciones pero cuando
estamos en la clase de cálculo se le
conoce más por su concepto de sumas de
riman ya que a partir de él se obtiene
la integral de riman si antes newton y
leibniz pues ya habían pensado en cosas
acerca de integrar pero riman llega
habla de su madre riman y pues su
definición se convierte digamos en la
definición más típica bueno vamos a
pensar que qué es esto de la integral de
riman y para eso imaginemos qué sucede
si n es muy grande tiene es muy muy
grande entonces tenemos una mejor
aproximación del área
del área que queda por debajo de la
gráfica de esta función entonces lo que
dice riman es mira o sea sí sí mientras
mayor sea line tienes una mejor
aproximación entonces a esta expresión
sácale su límite su límite límite de
cuando n tiende a infinito entonces
vamos a obtener el límite de cuando n
tiende a infinito como se vería esto oa
qué se refiere riman déjame hacer aquí
una una gráfica más o menos rápida ahí
tenemos el eje x por acá el eje y para y
tenemos una función sin voy a pintar un
poco más bonita
a esta ahí tenemos una función y
queremos determinar el área debajo de
esta gráfica entre a y b
entonces si n es muy muy grande lo que
sucede es que aquí vamos a tener muchos
muchos rectángulos la cosa que van a
aproximar bien bien la integral de modo
que si tomamos el límite de cuando n
tiene infinitos de estas aproximaciones
pues vamos a tener el área por debajo de
la gráfica de la función ba ok entonces
a esta expresión a este límite riman lo
reescribe lo re escribe así como la
integral la integral déjame poner un
poco más bonito mi signo de integral ahí
está como la integral de a a b de fx de
x y vamos a pensar tantito pensé en que
se parecen estas dos notaciones cómo se
conectan a que hay una f ya que hay una
f eso está muy bien pero mira que hay un
delta equis y que era ese delta equis
pues ese delta x venía de la longitud
verdad del largo de cada uno de los
rectángulos esto era delta x esto era
delta x todos estos eran delta x
entonces podemos pensar en de x como lo
que le sucede a delta x cuando n se va a
infinito o sea que estos se hacen así
super super flacos rectángulos muy muy
flacos entonces siendo un poquito
informales pero para darnos una idea
este de x podemos pensarlo como un como
un delta x infinitamente pequeño lo voy
a poner así entre comillas para para
decir que es un poco informal entonces
ni finita mente mitad mente pequeña
muy bien entonces podemos pensarlo
podemos pensarlo de esta manera va
entonces tenemos la f tenemos el el dx
que es un delta equis infinitamente
pequeño y aquí hay una sigma pero aquí
está este símbolo que básicamente lo que
nos está diciendo es que hagamos una
suma infinita de una infinidad de
rectángulos que están entre a y b bueno
lo vamos a dejar aquí para que pienses
tantito en cómo están conectadas
estas dos notaciones y para que pienses
tantito en esta definición y claro otra
vez recuerda esta expresión
esta suma vino de tus de una forma muy
particular de realizar la aproximación
utilizando el lado izquierdo para sacar
las alturas pero hay más son más de
riman también lo pudimos haber hecho con
el lado derecho con el punto medio o con
longitudes distintas bah pero la idea
principal es que si tomamos el límite de
cuando le tiene infinito de algunas de
las sumas de riman entonces obtenemos
esta definición de integral de rima
todavía no hemos platicado como
evaluarla cómo obtener un numerito pero
vamos a ver eso en los siguientes vídeos